this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at the highly requested game from
you guys Metal Gear Solid 5 which is
safe to say he had a lot of fun with
something absolutely hilarious about
trying to sneak up on guards with a
cardboard box on your head that's
amazing but not what I'm here to talk
about I'm not a cardboard box specialist
I'm a Firearms specialist if there are
any other games guns and mechanics that
you guys want to see Jonathan breakdown
let us know in the comment section below
and if you like this kind of content
we've got a brand new season of Loadout
airing on the channel right now new
episodes will launch every Sunday and
we've already got an episode in the
AK-47 and a deep dive into how games get
sniper rifles wrong on the channel
already right let's take a look at the
weapons of Metal Gear Solid 5.
foreign
this is not too far removed from a real
pistol design and I'm sure some of you
would already know or have spotted the
AMT Auto mag big old honking Magnum
pistol now it does this thing does
depart from reality in a number of ways
not least it appears to have a sort of
p38-esque slide rather than an internal
bolt like the real Auto mag but the
external look at the thing is pretty
close to the real thing where it really
parts company of course is in being a
suppressed tranquilizer pistol I'm not
aware of a suppressed version of the of
the auto mag and we've got a laser
module on the bottom of this thing
unless you squinted you probably would
wouldn't even pick up on its design
Heritage now I'm not an expert on
tranquilizer guns uh what I do know
about tranquilizer guns is they do not
take instant effects drug has to enter
the bloodstream and pass around the body
to take effect and you don't instantly
get knocked out you become drowsy and
unable to stand and you fall over in
which time you could have emptied your
firearm at your man here
quite quite comfortably otherwise we'd
probably fight wall with magic
tranquilizer guns
right we have a an
ak-esque thing but there are definite
design cues here notably in the pistol
grip and the lower receiver from the VZ
58 the check vz58 which is actually
quite different from the AK in terms of
how it operates otherwise though it's
kind of a fudge of of different AK based
systems the overall impression is maybe
a bit AKs 74u the the ribbed hand guard
that really makes this look like not an
AK is I don't know it calls to mind The
Germ East German Vega derivative of the
AK yeah I don't know I could I could
start I could list AK variants all day
long but I don't think any of them are a
very close match for this to be honest
with you funnily enough the butt stock
looks quite a lot like the one on the
Hungarian amp grenade firing rifle or
it's a derivative of the md65 intended
to also grenades and so the butt stop
actually reciprocates it's not for
adjustment it's it slides as you as you
fire and this looks pretty close to that
so what we have here is a sort of
Legally different AK essentially
right so what little I do know about
this game is that revolvers figure
pretty heavily as signature weapons for
for a couple of the main characters this
looks very chunky very heavy I can't
think of any particular design that this
matches it's far too bulky in the
receiver the barrel with the massive rib
on it it's pretty fancy stuff the
ability special ability that this
particular weapon can Ricochet bullets
off walls I'm not sure why it would be
specific why that would be specific as a
trade but it's either Ricochet or they
don't you can specifically or
deliberately I should say Ricochet
bullets well in a riot control situation
less lethal around are bounced off
sometimes bounced off the the ground to
ensure that no one is struck in a lethal
place but it's a very very a very rare
thing to be done deliberately and it's
not weapon specific needless to say
right another sort of I'm going to say
legally different I have a feeling
there's probably more to do with
creative license here than legal issues
suffice to say that this thing evokes uh
the FN FAL or maybe the FM Cal or the
fnfnc I think it's supposed to be in 556
so yeah bits of bits of all of those
really the receiver is kind of a bit
busy looking something we see in video
games is a sort of sometimes an over
designing of lines and angles and curves
where you know form follows function
typically in Firearms design each of
those angles and curves and shapes is
there for a reason up to a point you
know things like the F2000 we we
certainly are well into the um aesthetic
uh fashion aspects where the insides are
doing whatever and then the casing is
shaped aesthetically but when you're
talking about earlier machines machined
or stamped steel designs they they
typically are minimalist any unusual
design features are probably some
reinforcement for the sheet metal or
lightening cuts to try to make the
overall thing lighter but certainly
overall that with the front sight the
the gas tube Arrangement the butt Stark
and the overall impression it's it's
very FN for me
your suppressor is no longer effective
bear in mind your weapon will be loud
from now on calling back to one of our
Loadout episodes on suppressors or
silencers do go back and check that out
if you haven't seen it it's good stuff I
think not just because I'm in it reason
I mentioned that is we've just had a an
audio indication and I think the
suppressor must have blown off or
something that the sound suppressor on
this rifle has after a short period of
time spontaneously combusted which is
not something that happens you can use
suppressors basically all day long and
yeah they'll get dirty but um not really
an issue you might compromise their
effectiveness eventually if you use them
enough but they're not gonna they're not
gonna go from Silent to loud it's purely
a gameplay thing needless to say you
don't need me to tell you that
okay we've got weapon upgrades in this
game clearly to pressure on this one a
massive Optical sight almost looks like
a modern low power variable optic
mounted quite High very high actually
for the for the butt stop you'd need a
cheek piece to bring your your head up
in line with that otherwise it's not
going to work well jungle mags uh taped
magazines a vertical foregrip that's
right front fork grip that's uh the
pistol grip design for the rifle that's
something we see a lot the FBI HRT
hostage Rescue Team lodged four grips on
their mp5s the SAS did it for a while as
well it's a very common thing you get a
spare spare component and you and you
barge it on this before vertical
forklifts become standard but after
things like the Tommy Gun where again
that has basically a duplicate of its
pistol grip on the front
[Music]
all right yeah interesting one here this
is somewhat reminiscent of several eight
uh Heckler and Croc
um prototype submachine guns of the
1980s and early 90s I think smg1 smg2
where we get the mp7s sort of version of
the sliding butt stock seeing on the MP5
of course but uh where it where when
it's folded when it's shot it's kind of
integral to the design if that makes
sense and then you're pulling out the
back of the gun almost to create the
hotstock the straight mag the push pin
low receiver it's all very HK in fact
they're even the sights look like
they're inspired by those so this this
is a sort of what if you know if HK
carried on developing that instead of
ditching it and going with the mump
instead we might have something that
looks like this even the fire selector
in this and the symbology on there is
also reminiscent it looks cool like it
definitely looks like something HMK
might have produced as part of that
series
foreign
actual use we see that we don't have the
don't quite have the HK Diop to set up
and the charging handle is a rather low
profile almost scorpion machine
pistol-esque sort of nub in a bit bit
chunkier than that but not as pronounced
as anything like the MP5 or ump or those
prototype HK guns not ideal I would say
it would work but um that's maybe where
it would fall down as a functional
design
thank you
oh dear standard mad max-esque sonoff
shotgun but uh with a decidedly
non-standard large and bulky Optical
sight on it and a huge flashlight on the
left hand side we can here see these
weird proprietary rail attachment points
that I don't see how they're supposed to
work nice in a way that they've put them
on there so that you're attaching it to
something but in a way I probably would
have preferred proprietary mounts you
know if someone was Drilling and tapping
and fitting fitting the the actual mount
for the thing straight on rather than
implying that this is some Advanced
clip-on clip-off system that uh if it
has a practical way of working I can't
see how it would more importantly you
don't want a great big optical sight and
a flashlight on a essentially giant
pistol
laughs
okay so I take I take it back slightly
because the bulky Optical site is
actually a red dot sight and Old Red Dot
sights were bulky but uh still not ideal
for a Sono shotgun I would suggest I
suppose I suppose the flashlight is
always useful I just I wouldn't
necessarily attach it to a weapon like
this then again I don't know how else
you'd hold it because you need both
hands on this on this puppy you can you
can fire sort of shotguns one-handed but
uh some of shotguns aren't really
recommended for anything to be honest
with you especially not without a butt
stop
yeah
[Music]
this belt [ __ ] machine gun despite
being 556 in the game is well I was
going to say it's based on the FN mag 58
but it's kind of based on the whole FN
machine gun family I think the furniture
is more minimy the receiver is pretty
pretty close to the mag 58 but it has
more rivets almost like it's mashed up
with a PKM so what I've done because we
don't have anything that's going to
match this exactly is an excuse to show
you a recent acquisition of ours this is
a genuine
Mark 46 Mod 0 an actual U.S military it
well probably not issue but uh made for
the US Military and we have relatively
few Firearms of that nature we often
have the same type but we don't have one
with the markings and the specific
configuration so the Mark 46 is
minimally derived felt bed machine gun
in 5.56 millimeter partly why I chose it
for this you can see the family
resemblance definitely with the bus stop
and the pistol grip the great big gas
tube underneath is a little bit hidden
by the handguard on this but it's the
same basic design as you see there being
a lightweight Design This has a very
short and fluted barrel it's not on this
one that has a barrel much more
reminiscent of the bl7 the m240 but yeah
just a really cool modern lightweight
Special Forces lmg essentially and in a
funny sort of way I think this is a
better choice than the the full sort of
squad belt fed gun configuration that
I'm seeing in front of me but I'm mixed
expecting customization that would make
this a closer fit to this gun
okay pretty pretty strong Uzi Heritage
on this submachine gun mini uzi to be
precise similar sort of butt start
similar sort of receiver shape but
substantially altered to not look too
much like an easy for for whatever
reason the blue I don't understand but
I'm guessing is relevant to some
ammunition characteristic we've got
magazines clipped together perpendicular
to each other that's something we do see
in real life not done too too commonly
but it is done now of course with
something as compact as a mini uzi You
Are by putting a big long suppressor on
it and a red dot sight on the top jungle
mags you're making this thing as big and
bulky or something like an xm177 AR-15
Carbine may as well have that and get
rifle caliber ballistics
there's something absolutely hilarious
about trying to sneak up on guards with
a cardboard box on your head that's
amazing
um but not what I'm here to talk about
I'm not a cardboard box specialist I'm a
Firearms specialist so I gather that the
the blue which I very cleverly not
really did use was some sort of
ammunition type funnily enough it is a
the same sort of shade of blue that's
used for uh hk's plastic training rounds
and simunition things like that to make
sure that the weapon you're using you
know what it's set up to Fire and you
don't accidentally involve any live
ammunition here the idea is you're using
effectively training ammunition to less
lethally incapacitate people which is
not possible and not a good idea this
has no connection to reality well the
only connection it does have of course
is right right weapons that are less
lethal that shoot some sort of polymer
once rubber sometimes nylon those hat
though are something like 37 40
millimeters and are big and heavy to
give you that impact to actually have
any kind of effect pain compliance
essentially is how those work if you
need to go lesson lethal a beanbag
shotgun taser yeah there are various
options out there but in this scenario
it doesn't make too much sense it's not
a great way to go about it
all right next up uh more more period
appropriate green Furniture I proved of
that that was that was a thing for a
while I say 80 is still wearing it's um
green furniture at least some of it this
is very reminiscent of the six series of
rifles maybe a little bit of G3 thrown
in and it's got a one of these less
lethal barrels attached you will see
this um it's probably what it's based on
actually sometimes they'll replace the
whole barrel with bright blue or bright
yellow if it's blank firing and then
swap the barrel back in for lethal
purpose
[Music]
sniper rifle time big old chunky thing I
would assume this is meant to be 50
caliber big old brake heavy barrel very
long magazine uh in fact everything
about this thing is Big weirdly the
scope looks out of proportion and too
small but not here not there the only
immediate thing that comes to mind here
is how bulky and blocky that stock is
then again this thing's ahead of its
time based on when this is supposed to
take place this this is very very close
to an accurate International aw50 which
did not exist in this time frame
functionally and I don't see why it
wouldn't work except that the magazine
is very very embedded in that big blocky
polymer stock chassis thing and would be
a little bit hard to extract and it
typically rifles will have rifles like
this will have more exposed magazines so
you have to leave for them out someone
and there isn't room for the Levering as
far as I can see
all right well I can see the bones of a
gp25 or that series of Soviet design
grenade launcher in this thing but yeah
it's uh it's pretty cursed I'm not aware
of a standalone grip stock for these but
even as I say that I'd be surprised if
there wasn't one they are they were
designed as under Barrel launchers for
about the akm and then the AK-74 this
one's Bulgarian they attach to the
bayonet or the or a secondary in this
case bayonet lug with a with a push
catch so they're somewhat quick detach
you you definitely fit them to a grip
stop that's not the problem the problem
is the way these work I can demonstrate
this is clear it's muzzle loaded and
then double action trigger so you pull
back and you can see it all it's doing
is dragging the hammer back
and letting it fall very simple
mechanism and that has to be in line
with the breach well I don't have a
breach but with the uh the back of the
barrel for the firing pin to protrude
and fire the semi-caseless round which
is to say that multiples of them of the
barrels with nothing directly behind
them cannot be fired so this is a
complete this is a non-functional design
other than the what the barrel that's in
direct line with
trigger mechanism now really you'd need
some kind of Fairly sophisticated
linkage to deliver enough Force to the
firing pin to fire off well you need a
second Hammer below this Hammer operated
by both triggers and I'm not seeing a
ready means of achieving that
[Music]
oh right Bullpup this is definitely in
my wheelhouse this is not based on
anything British this is a really quite
interesting mashup of G36
French famous maybe the G11 as well in
the in the low receiver area quite a
sound looking design I like the fact
that they describe what Bullpup means
that's nice as to it enabling quicker
aiming and firing that's that's
debatable and is being debated all the
time I don't think I'm gonna weigh in on
on that one well okay so the theoretical
advantage that we can't really argue
about is that it makes it easier to fire
one-handed but you know you're only
doing that in an emergency anyway
do that
[Laughter]
oh dear
that's absurd
well that was absolutely absurd but uh
lots of fun as well so what what can I
say about a rocket arm
not sure how he's getting it back after
use there's a there's a weird nod to
realism there in that the arm is I don't
know using compressed air or a small
small charge to launch it on the rocket
motor then kicks in and you you do your
thing with it sum is a whole game up
really an oddly thoughtful and somewhat
realistic Edge to an absolutely absurd
idea
thank you
thank you boss let me just thank you for
spritzing in with water wow well what a
gun to finish on I have no idea what the
context of this thing in the game is I
think even in this game it has to be a
sort of joke thing clearly it I mean the
way it's described in sort of like
everything else as though it's a real
weapon makes me laugh reminds me of the
um April fools we did a couple of years
ago for Splatoon too the gun or it looks
a little bit less generic self-loading
pistol design bit of CZ 75 in there
maybe nothing what else at the moment
but then it has a plunger style uh water
pistol trigger it literally just sprayed
water
what can I say lit leaves a leaves a wet
patch when it when it hits so again
attention to detail
right well a lot of you asked for that
one and uh it was a lot of fun to do I
must say thanks for watching as always
you can always check out the Royal
armories YouTube accounts social media
the website if you're able to come and
visit us we'd love you to do that and
that's sort of request number one for a
museum really uh come and see us if you
can obviously we understand if you can't
and we're really happy to be working
with Gamespot on getting the collection
out there especially for those of you
who can't make it thanks a lot we'll see
you next time
how about
[Music]